The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANDREW LO: Well, if you remember
last time where we left off,
we were talking about
risk and return.
And we said that we
were going to make
the following simplifying
assumption, which
is that we're going to
assume that investors
like expected return,
and they do not like risk
as measured by volatility.
All right?
And so the way that we
depict it graphically
is to use a graph
where the x-axis is
standard deviation of
your entire portfolio,
and the y-axis is the expected
return of that portfolio.
And the question is,
where on this graph
can we get to, given the
securities that we have access
to, that will maximize
our level of happiness.
Where happiness,
again, is assumed
to mean higher expected rate
of return and lower risk,
as measured by variance
or standard deviation.
So for example, if you take
a look at this simple graph
and you ask the question, where
on the graph do you want to be,
you would like to
be always going
in the northwest direction.
Right?
Because north means higher
expected return and west
means lower risk.
So obviously, if we could,
we'd love to be on this axis
all the way, way up.
Right?
No risk, lots of return.
That's an example
of an arbitrage.
And we know that
that can't happen
very easily because otherwise
everybody would be there.
And pretty soon it would
wipe out that opportunity.
So the question from the
portfolio construction
perspective is now a little bit
sharper than it was last week
when we started down this path.
Now we want to
construct a portfolio,
we want to take a
collection of securities
and weight them in order
to be as happy as possible.
Meaning, we want to be
as northwest as possible.
So let's see how we
go about doing that.
One thing we could do is just
pick an individual stock.
So if you have these four
stocks to pick from, then
to go as northwest
as possible, you're
sort of looking at Merck
as, you know, the extreme.
But it's not at all clear
whether or not that's something
that you really want.
Because, for example,
General Motors,
while it has a lower expected
return than Merck, it does
have a bit of a lower risk.
And for some people, that
might actually be preferred.
So at this point, we don't have
a lot of hard recommendations
to provide you with, without
any further analysis.
So we're going to do some
further analysis today.
And the analysis is to ask
the question, all right, what
are the properties of mean and
variance for a given portfolio,
not just for an
individual security.
So it turns out that there's a
relatively straightforward way
of answering this.
And let me just go
through the calculations
and then we can see
what that implies
for where we want to be in that
mean-standard deviation graph.
So the mean of a
particular stock I'm
going to write as expectation
of Ri, or mu i, for short.
The variance of a
particular stock
I'm going to write
as sigma squared i,
or the standard deviation
is then just sigma i.
OK?
And it turns out, you
can show this rigorously.
I won't do that, but you
can take a look at that
if you are unconvinced.
It turns out that if you
construct a weighted average
of stocks so that the
return of the portfolio
is given by that
top line, R sub p,
then when you take the expected
value of that top line, what
you get is the middle line.
In other words, the expected
return of a portfolio
is just equal to the exact
same weighted averages
of the expected rates of return
of the individual components.
So you understand the
difference between the second
and the first line
in that red box?
That's a very
important distinction.
The top line is basically
an accounting identity.
It says that when you want to
compute the actual realized
return in your
portfolio, you just
take a weighted average of what
you did on each stock, what
your return is on each stock.
That's an accounting identity.
The second line is not
an accounting identity.
It comes from an
accounting identity.
But what it says
is that on average,
the rate of return
of your portfolio
is equal to a weighted average
of the average rates of return
on each of the components
of your portfolio.
OK?
That's a very
important principle.
Any questions about
that before we move on?
OK.
So I'm going to write that as a
shorthand for the portfolio, mu
sub p.
So mu sub p is just equal
to this whole expression
right here.
All right.
So what we've now deduced is
that the mean of my portfolio
is simply the weighted
average of the means of each
of the securities
in the portfolio.
What I'm going to turn to next
is a much more complicated
calculation, which is, what is
the variance of my portfolio.
It turns out that the
variance of the portfolio
is not a simple weighted
average of the variances
of my individual securities.
This is where it
gets complicated,
and also where it gets really
interesting and valuable
from the investor's perspective.
OK.
Let's do the calculation.
You're going to have to dredge
up your old DMD knowledge here
of how to compute variances
of sums of random variables.
The variance of my
portfolio return, R sub p,
is simply equal to the expected
value of the excess return
of that portfolio, in
excess of its mean,
right, squared, and then
take the expectation of that.
And remember that the
return of the portfolio
is just a weighted
average of the returns
of the individual securities.
And the mean of the portfolio is
just the same weighted average
of the means of the securities.
So when you plug those
relationships in, what you get
is that the variance is
simply equal to the expected
value of the square of
this long weighted average.
So you've got a weighted
average, a bunch of terms,
right?
And then you square
that and then
you take the expected value.
Well, if you've got n terms
in that weighted average,
and you square that n
terms, how many terms
comes out of that square?
Anybody?
n terms, and you
square those n terms,
so those n terms
multiplied by itself,
how many terms do you
get when you do that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Well, why
not just n squared?
You're thinking about the
unique elements, maybe,
the off diagonal.
I'm talking about all of them.
So with n terms,
when you square it,
n terms multiplied by n terms,
you get n times n terms,
n squared terms.
And so these n squared
terms all look like this.
They all look like
omega i times omega
j multiplied by the
excess return of i
times the excess return of j.
Sometimes i equals j.
And when that happens,
you get omega i squared
times the variance
of security i.
But when i does not
equal to j, then you're
going to get omega i times
omega j times the covariance
between the return on i and j.
And another way of
writing that covariance
is equal to the
correlation between i
and j multiplied by the
standard deviation of i
and the standard deviation of j.
The point is that when we look
at the variance of a portfolio,
it's not just the
simple weighted average
of the variances of
the component stocks.
It's actually a weighted average
of all the cross products,
where the weights are also the
cross products of the weights.
So it's these.
It's all of these.
And how many of these are there?
Well, i goes from 1 to n, j
goes from 1 to n, n times n,
you get n squared of these.
So this actually has
a nice representation.
It actually comes
out of a table.
Right?
So you can think of all of the
portfolio weights multiplied
by the excess returns
on one dimension
of the table, the columns,
and the exact same entries
in the rows.
You've got n columns,
n rows, n times n,
or n squared
elements that make up
the variance of your portfolio.
So this is where it
gets really complicated.
But this is why we have
computers and spreadsheets
and things like that.
So in order to figure out the
variance of your portfolio,
you've got to basically add all
of the elements in this table.
You've got n squared
things to add up
to get the variance
of your portfolio.
And the insight of
modern finance theory--
the reason that Harry
Markowitz won the Nobel Prize
in economics for this idea--
is that when you add up all
of these different elements,
you can get results that
are very different from just
looking at one or two stocks.
Because, in
particular, there are
some cases where
these cross products
are either small or
maybe even negative.
And in that case,
it actually helps
you to reduce the overall
riskiness of your portfolio.
This is the intuition.
This is the
mathematics underlying,
don't put all your
eggs in one basket.
When you don't put all your
eggs in one basket, what you're
getting, what you're
benefiting from,
are these cross
products that can either
be small or negative,
and will ultimately
reduce the fluctuations
of your portfolio.
Another way of thinking about
it is that some stocks go up,
some stocks go down.
And if they don't go up and
down in the exact same way,
if they are unrelated
or less related,
then when you put it all
together in a portfolio
it dampens the riskiness
of your overall holdings.
OK.
So there are n squared
elements that you
have to add up in order to
get the portfolio variance.
It's literally the sum of all
of the entries in this table.
And the point of the
next few bullet points
is that there are a
lot more covariances
than there are variances.
The variances are along the
diagonal of that table, right?
That's the variance
of the first stock,
the variance of the
second stock, dot,
dot, dot, the variance
of the n stock.
Those are how volatile
the individual stocks are.
But there are only n of those.
There are n squared minus
n of the other stuff.
That's where you were thinking
about n minus 1, right?
It's n squared minus n,
or n times n minus 1.
Other non-diagonal entries.
So what this suggests is that
the covariances are a lot more
important in determining the
riskiness of your portfolio
than the riskiness of
the individual stocks.
You know, Intel looks
like a scary stock
because it's really volatile.
But when you've got n
Intels in your portfolio,
even though each of
the individual stocks
is scary, what you have
to keep your eye on
is how they are correlated.
Because the correlations
in a portfolio of n
stocks is actually
more important
than the individual variances.
The individual variances
matter, but they
don't matter nearly as
much as the covariances.
OK?
So now I'm going
to do an example.
It's hard to get intuition
for n by n matrices,
unless you're Rain Man,
or some incredible genius.
The way that I think about this
is, let's look at two assets.
OK?
If I can understand two assets,
I can sort generalize and think
about n assets.
So I gave you the
general result just
to tell you that this
is how you do it.
But now to understand
it, really,
let's focus just on two assets.
OK?
Suppose we only have
two stocks, a and b.
And I'm going to calculate the
expected return and standard
deviation of a portfolio
with just those two stocks.
So the portfolio
weights are going
to be omega a for stock a,
and omega b for stock b.
And omega a plus
omega b adds up to 1.
So just keep that in mind.
I don't put it
there just because I
want to save a little
space on the slide.
But these are the weights
for the two stocks.
And those are the only
two things you hold.
All right?
The expected value
is as we said.
It's a weighted average
of your holdings of
and b, right, multiplied by the
mean of a and the mean of b.
Now the variance, the variance
of these two securities
when they are put
into a portfolio
is going to be simply
omega a squared
times the variance
of a plus omega
b squared times
the variance of b.
And now you only have
one cross product
to worry about because
you've only got two stocks.
Right?
And that is 2 times
omega a times omega
b times the covariance
between a and b.
Now you can do this in a 2
by 2 table, just like the n
by n table.
And with a 2 by
2 table, you know
that you've got two diagonal
elements and two off
diagonal elements.
And that's where you get
that number 2 for the 2 times
omega a, omega b
times the covariance.
OK?
And I rewrite it in
terms of correlations
because it's easier to think
in terms of correlations.
Why?
Because correlations
we know have
to be between minus 1 and 1.
And so if I tell you a stock
has a correlation with another
of 30%, you can actually
get your arms around that.
You can get intuition for that.
All right?
So it's a little
easier to interpret.
But either way is fine.
So we now have an
expression for the mean
and the variance of a
portfolio of two assets.
Any questions about this?
Everybody understand
this and how I got it?
No tricks up my sleeve.
It's really meant to be
relatively straightforward.
But the implications
will be dramatic,
as I'm going to show
you in a minute.
OK.
So let me go through at
least one numerical example.
And then I'm going to show
you why this is actually
so important.
From 1946 to 2001, Motorola
had an average monthly return
of 1.75%, and a standard
deviation of 9.73%.
General Motors had an
average return of 1.08%,
and a standard
deviation of 6.23%.
That has obviously since
gone up a great deal,
the standard deviation, that is.
And their correlation
is 0.37, or 37%.
How would a portfolio of
the two stocks perform?
Well, it depends.
What are the weights?
Right?
If you change the
weights, you're
going to change the performance.
So let's just take a look.
If you put all your weight
on General Motors and nothing
on Motorola, not
surprisingly, you're
going to get General
Motors' return.
At the other end of the extreme,
if you put all your weight
on Motorola and nothing
on General Motors,
you're going to get
Motorola's characteristics.
All right?
Nothing mysterious about that.
However, if you weight the
two, so if you put 50-50
on General Motors
and Motorola, you're
going to get a return that is
50-50 of each of those returns.
But you're going to get
a risk that is not 50-50.
Right?
Because the risks,
the risks don't
aggregate in a linear way.
The risks actually
aggregate non-linearly
because of those
covariances or correlations.
OK.
So what you see here
is that by taking
a weighted average of
the two, what you can do
is you can boost
your return to 1.42%,
but the extra risk
you're taking is
from 6.23% to 6.68% per month.
That's not a big
increase in risk,
but that is a pretty
significant increase in return.
Now again, I'm not telling you
that's what you all should do,
because it depends on
your risk preferences.
And for the next
lecture or two, I'm
going to be saying that
over and over again.
I'm going to be saying
it depends upon your risk
preferences.
But at the end of the
next two lectures,
I'm going to be able to tell
you something that doesn't
depend on your risk preference.
I'm going to be able to tell
you something that all of you
should be willing to
do if you're rational.
And if you're not, I will
trade with you personally
to help you learn rationality.
OK?
But for now, I
don't have a story
to tell you about which of
these rows you ought to take.
There is no ought to here.
It's just a matter of what you
prefer, risk versus return.
Right?
Now interestingly, I
put here one more case
which lies outside
of the band of 0, 1.
This is a case where you've
put 125% of your wealth
into Motorola.
And you've put negative
25% of your wealth
into General Motors.
Remember, we talked about
this in the very beginning.
You're using short
selling to short sell
General Motors,
which you might think
is not a bad idea nowadays,
given how troubled they are.
You're going to short General
Motors, take the proceeds,
and put that plus the 100%
that you started with,
you're going to put
that in Motorola.
So you really want to make
a big bet on communications
and microprocessors.
And you're going
to leverage that
bet by putting a negative
bet on the auto industry.
That's what that
last row implies.
And what you get is a
much, much higher rate
of return than anything
else in the other examples.
Right?
Much higher rate of return.
But look at the risk.
Now the risk is
close to double what
you would have gotten had you
put all your money in General
Motors.
Are you willing to do that?
Well, you can
easily imagine there
are people in this class that
would be delighted to do that,
and there are others of you
that would be scared to death.
That's way too much volatility.
These are monthly
numbers, by the way.
So if you want to calculate
the annual equivalent,
how would you do that?
How would you get an
annual standard deviation
from a monthly
standard deviation?
Any idea?
Well, let's do the return first.
How do you annualize the monthly
return to get an annual return?
Let's forget about compounding.
What would you do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW LO: What?
Multiply by 12.
That's right.
If you forget about
confounding, you multiply by 12.
What if you didn't
forget about compounding?
Then what do you do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Add 1, raise
it to the 12th power,
then subtract 1.
That's right.
OK.
What about risk?
Ah, see?
This is tricky.
What's the variance
of a 12-month return
in relationship to the
variance of a one-month return?
We haven't talked about that.
What is it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: No.
No.
It doesn't compound in that way.
Variance is actually
a little simpler,
under certain assumptions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Right.
There's no correlation
between one month to the next.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: That's right.
Agreed.
So let's assume that away.
Then it's constant.
But the monthly
variance is constant.
But what's the annual variance?
What's the riskiness
of a 12-month return
if you know what the riskiness
of a one-month return is?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Well, it can,
depending on your assumptions.
But I want a simple
set of assumptions.
Andy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Variance, yes.
Multiply by 12.
Now why is that?
It's because-- and
you know all this.
You know this from your DMD.
At least I think you do.
You may not think
you do, but you do.
The variance of a plus
b is equal to what?
Who can tell me?
What's the variance of a plus b?
Two random variables.
Variance of a plus
variance of b plus 2 times
the covariance of a and b.
If the covariance is 0,
then it is the variance
of a plus the variance of b.
Absolutely, that's right.
So if we assume
there are no cycles,
there are no predictabilities,
there's no regularities,
there's no correlation,
every month
is independent of
every other month,
than the variance
of a 12-month return
is literally just 12 times the
variance of a one-month return,
assuming the variances stay
constant throughout the month.
The monthly variance
doesn't go up or down.
OK?
Now, that's the variance.
What about the
standard deviation?
The standard deviation is the
square root of the variance.
So that means that the standard
deviation on an annualized
basis is equal to square root of
12 times the standard deviation
of a monthly.
OK.
So finally, we're almost there.
What's the square root of 12?
Something between
3 and 4, right?
So I don't know, call
it 3 and 1/2, whatever.
We have to take this number and
multiply it by about 3 and 1/2.
And that will get us an
approximate annual standard
deviation.
So a 12% volatility
multiplied by 3 and 1/2,
you're talking about some crazy
volatile stock, or portfolio.
But actually,
nowadays, you know,
we're used to that
kind of volatility.
That's no big deal.
But relative to the
individual stock,
it's quite a bit more volatile.
OK?
So this is an example
of how you compute
the riskiness and the return
of a portfolio of two stocks.
And when you do this, you get
a whole bunch of possibilities.
And the idea behind
modern portfolio theory
is you pick the one
that you like the best.
And that's optimal for you.
Now let me graph this in that
mean-standard deviation graph,
and you'll see something
really interesting.
So here's General Motors
and there is Motorola.
And what I've graphed
with the red dots
is just the different
combinations of 25/75,
50/50, 75/25, and so on.
And so the red dots that are
strictly between 0 and 1,
where the weights are between
0 and 1, those are the dots
contained in that arc
between GM and Motorola.
So the first point
I want to make
is that when you graph
the risk/reward trade-off,
as I told you, it's not linear.
It's non-linear.
In fact, it's curved.
It looks like a bullet.
OK?
That tells you right
away that there's
something more subtle
about portfolio theory
than just taking
weighted averages.
The means are weighted
averages, but the variances
are not because of the
covariance between them.
And then when you
take the square root
to get the standard deviation,
it looks a little bit more
complicated, yet again.
It looks like this.
Now that red dot that
goes beyond Motorola,
that red dot is the case where
you're shorting General Motors
and you're using the proceeds
to take an extra large position
in Motorola.
OK?
So you're going beyond the
Motorola risk/reward point.
So I need you to spend
a little bit of time
now twisting your
brain in a way that
makes this more understandable.
What I mean by that
is that you have
to think about the weights
of the various different
portfolios.
But the weights don't
show up on this graph.
But I want you to
keep those weights
in the back of your head.
So while you're
looking at this graph,
you have to remember
that as you move along,
that bullet, the omegas,
the weights are changing.
So at the General Motors dot,
your weight for General Motors
is a 100% and your
weight for Motorola is 0.
At the Motorola dot, your
weight for General Motors is 0
and your weight for
Motorola is 100%.
And as you vary the weights,
you trace this arc, this curve.
And as you go beyond either
General Motors or Motorola--
in other words,
as you short sell
one to invest more
than 100% in the other,
you then go outside of the two
points in either direction.
Right?
Any questions about this graph?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: OK.
So how do you calculate
the correlation?
That's a good question.
Historically, the
way you would do it
is exactly the way
that these correlations
look like they're defined.
So in other words, you would
calculate the covariance
by essentially taking
a historical average
of these cross products.
So going back to the first slide
in this particular lecture,
I gave you a formula that
shows you how to do that.
Let me go back and
take a look at it
so that you refresh your memory.
Let's see.
Oh, it was not in this lecture.
It was in the previous lecture.
In a previous
lecture, I gave you
a formula that shows
you how to calculate
the weighted average of this,
or the historical average.
It's basically just
taking historical data
and then estimating this
quantity right here,
this particular cross product.
The omega weights come
out, because that's
what you get to decide.
But the inside stuff, how
to calculate that is simply
to take, historically, your
actual return minus the mean
of i, Rjt minus the mean of
j, and then take 1 over t,
and that's your estimator
for the sigma hat ij.
So you get historical data and
you would estimate the mean,
estimate the mean, take the
cross products over time.
This t goes from 1 to t, and
that gets you an estimator.
Is that the best estimator?
Not necessarily, because
things change over time.
So you have to worry about that.
And that's what
you learn in 15433,
how to actually implement a
lot of these ideas using data.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: OK.
So the question is, is there
any recommended length of time
for which you would go
about estimating the data,
estimating these
quantities using the data?
The answer is no.
There's no recommended
time, simply because you
have to trade off two things.
The longer time you
have, the more accurate
your estimate is going to be.
In the limit, as t
goes to infinity,
you'll get a perfect estimator.
OK?
However, that's
under the assumption
that nothing ever changes.
And I'm pretty sure
that beyond some t,
over let's say 150 or
200 years, you know,
we didn't exist in terms
of stock markets and data.
I don't think that, for
example, General Motors
goes back 200 years.
So beyond some t, this is
going to look very boring.
But the other thing
you have to trade off
is the fact that market
conditions change.
So General Motors today is
not what General Motors was,
even 10 years ago.
So if you use lots
of data, you're
going to build into
your results what
are called non-stationarities.
And the bottom line is
you have to balance off
the non-stationarities
against the error
that you introduce by
not using enough data.
And that really is
where 15433 comes in.
So there are methods
that we have developed
for balancing those two.
But the bottom line is that
there isn't one single answer.
So it depends on how
unstable the markets are
and how volatile the underlying
estimates are, given the data.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Well, sure.
You could try to
include a full cycle.
But then you're left
with the question,
the full cycle of what?
For example, there
are these things
called Kondratiev
cycles that claim to be
something like 50 year periods.
So if you want to
include one of those,
you've got to include
50 years of data.
But do you really think
that General Motors
is the same company
over those 50 years?
You're building in a
lot of bias in terms
of the non-stationarity
of one aspect,
while incorporating
the stationarities
of another aspect.
So how do you balance
off those two, right?
This is where it
gets more complex.
And you have to take a stand on
the kind of non-stationarities
that are in the data.
Other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Well, first
of all, we're not trying
to predict the stock market.
Remember, we're not
trying to predict
where markets are going to go.
What we're suggesting
is that there
are underlying parameters of the
data that are stable over time.
So in other words, the stocks
can go up or down, right?
But on average, they
have some level of return
that people expect,
given their risk.
That's what we're
assuming is stable.
Similarly, covariances.
Stocks can go up or
down in relationship
to other stocks
going down or up.
We don't know what's going
to happen day to day.
But over a period
of time, it seems
like there's a pattern where
most stocks on the New York
and American stock
exchanges and NASDAQ,
they seem to go up together
and they seem to go
down together, on average.
So that's what,
really, what we're
trying to distill from the data.
It's very different
than trying to forecast
what's going to happen with
the stock market next week.
And this, I told you, is
the fundamental difference
between academic finance
and Warren Buffett.
Warren Buffett is
all about prediction.
He's not about creating
a good portfolio that
will be worth something
reasonable over a period
of time.
What he wants to do is he
wants to beat the market.
He wants to find undervalued
stocks, invest in them,
and then sell them when they
actually reach equilibrium
or become overvalued.
Right?
That's a very different
approach and perspective
than what we're doing here.
So that's a good question, and
it highlights that distinction.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Yes, there is.
And there have been many studies
that have been done on it.
And that is beyond the
scope of this course.
So I'm going to refer
you, again, to 15433.
But I will tell you,
at the end of this,
once I get through this and
make sure everybody is with me,
I will tell you how
this works in practice.
OK?
So I'll talk a bit
about applications.
But first I want to
get through the theory
to make sure we
all understand it.
All right.
So we now have this bullet.
And the bullet obviously
depends on all the parameters.
But in particular, it
depends upon the correlation.
The reason that there
is a bullet shape
is because there is a
correlation between these two
stocks.
And by the way, this correlation
and this bullet shape
is really important.
OK?
I'll tell you why
it's really important.
Take a look at a vertical
slice, a vertical line
going through the GM dot.
That vertical line is
the riskiness of GM.
Right?
It's the standard
deviation of GM.
One of the things that you'll
notice about this graph
is that if you only had two
stocks available to you, GM
and Motorola, the least amount
of risk that you could possibly
create for yourself is if you
put 100% in General Motors.
In other words, if all you
cared about was going west,
the most extreme
west you can go other
than putting your
money in T-bills
over here, the most extreme west
you can go is General Motors.
You can't get any
less risky than that.
Yeah?
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: What I'm
saying is, if you
are trying to get less
risky as possible,
and you only had General
Motors or Motorola,
then the most west you
can go is General Motors.
Right?
That's all.
However, however, this
is the important point.
If now I let you take
weighted averages of the two,
if I give you the right
to form a portfolio,
then you can get a dot,
which is this dot right here.
That dot, everybody in
this room should prefer
that dot to General Motors.
Why?
Because it's less risk
than General Motors,
but it's also higher return.
There's no downside, at
least from the perspective
of mean and standard deviation.
There may be other reasons
you don't like that dot.
But if all you care about is
mean and standard deviation,
that dot is strictly preferred.
So I just made all
of you better off
with this piece of knowledge.
Just by telling you
how to weight these two
stocks and the fact that they've
got some kind of correlation,
I've given you a mechanism
of reducing your risk and,
and increasing your expected
rate of return, both.
OK?
So if you were
really risk averse,
if you said to
yourself, you know what?
I don't want all this
fancy stock picking.
Just give me the least
risky stock of the two.
Then you'd be at General Motors.
And then if I came to you
and said, you know what?
I can do even better than that.
I can get even less risk
than General Motors.
And at the same time, I'm going
to give you higher return.
So right there, the
value of portfolio theory
is pretty clear.
It gives you options
you did not have.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
ANDREW LO: That's right.
That's right.
When you have correlations
that are unstable over time
and you didn't account for
them, you can get into trouble.
OK?
Again, let's come back to that
after I go through all of this.
All right?
So, just if this is a clarifying
question, I'll answer.
But extensions, let's wait until
we actually go through this.
OK.
So let me talk about the General
Motors and Motorola example,
but now where I am going to
tell you that correlations
are changing over time.
So let's do the example
that Lewis wants us to do.
Let's actually assume
the correlation
is, I don't know,
0 or 1 or minus 1.
Let's go through all three
cases and see what happens.
You'll see some remarkable
things coming out of this.
If the correlation is 0,
then it's pretty easy for you
to just plug in 0
for that correlation
in that second equation.
And all you get are
the first two terms
of that variance expression.
Right?
So when you assume that the--
when you assume that
the correlation is
0, when this thing
is 0, what happens
is that this entire
term goes away
and all you have are
the first two terms.
That's this column
right over here.
OK?
So I've just produced
the previous table
but with the assumption of 0
correlation, and I get that.
Now I'm not going to
graph it for you yet.
I want to just show you
what happens when you
choose different assumptions.
So that's one assumption.
On the other hand, if I
choose a different assumption,
if I choose the assumption
that the correlation is,
let's say 1--
so in other words, they
are perfectly correlated--
then I'm going to get,
I'm going to get this.
I'm going to get
this becoming 1,
and then I'll get
another simplification
of this expression.
And similarly, if I assume that
the correlation is minus 1,
then I'm going to get yet
another simplification
of this expression.
It's an algebra that I'll
show you in a minute.
But this is what I'm doing
in these three columns.
I'm assuming different values
of correlation between General
Motors and Motorola,
and then computing
the standard deviation of the
portfolio using this formula.
OK?
So you can all do this at
home, do this in a spreadsheet.
It's going to be very
easy to check my work.
But I want to show you the
graph because that's really,
I think, the insightful
intuition here.
Look at the graphs.
These are the graphs of
the three different cases
of zero correlation,
perfect correlation,
and perfect negative
correlation.
I want to go to each
one of these with you.
So the case of perfect
positive correlation,
it turns out that the
risk/reward trade off is
actually just a straight line.
It gets really, really simple.
It's just a straight line.
So in particular, there
is no non-linearity.
Because if they're perfectly
correlated, you know what?
You basically have
virtually the same stock.
The only difference
is that they're
different scales of each other.
Right?
But if they're
perfectly correlated,
that means that there's a linear
relationship between those two
stocks.
And so when you do this
mean variance analysis,
in mean variance
space, you basically
get no nonlinear-- you
don't get that little bump,
the little bullet
that we saw before.
Right?
So there's no way you can get
less risk than General Motors
unless you end up shorting
Motorola and putting it
in General Motors.
And then your expected
return goes down,
as well as your risk.
All right.
Now let's take the case where
you've got no correlation.
It turns out that if
you have no correlation,
you get the bullet.
But the bullet is even
more wedge shaped.
What that means is that you
can reduce even more risk
without getting rid of return.
Remember the red dot that we
saw in the previous slide?
This red dot?
Well, in the case where
you've got 0 correlation--
this is the case where the
correlation is 0.37, 37%.
Right?
That's what the data tells us.
But if you assume that
the correlation was zero,
you would get even more
of a savings of volatility
for a given level
of expected return.
OK?
So it would look like this.
You see how this
bullet sticks out
a lot more than the
previous red dot that
was somewhere over here?
OK?
Now let's continue.
Suppose the correlation
is minus 50%.
Then you get an
even wider bullet,
that sticks out even
more, that saves you
more standard deviation.
You're getting to
the west even more.
And finally, and here is where
you get a really remarkable
result. If the
correlation is minus 100%,
you know what you get?
You get a piecewise
linear trade off.
You get this and that.
It doesn't turn into a wedge.
It turns into a triangle that
actually hits the x-axis.
And the reason this is
such a startling result
is it tells us that
there exists a way
to construct a portfolio that
gives us a rate of return
of like 1.39% with no risk.
Zero risk.
1.39%.
Let's just call it 1.3%
to be conservative.
Multiply that by
12 and you're going
to get something like what?
16% a year?
You tell me if you know of any
investment opportunities that
gives you a return of
16% a year with no risk,
and I'll examine that
for you carefully.
OK?
It doesn't exist, of course.
The reason it doesn't
exist is because you
can't find two assets that have
perfect negative correlation.
If you could, there
are wondrous things
you could achieve
with that combination.
And portfolio theory
basically tells us how, right?
This is a recipe book for
how to exploit correlation.
All right?
Now again, I can't
tell you where
you should be on
this curve other
than if it's really minus
1, then I would be here.
OK?
Lots of return, no risk.
That's an arbitrage.
We know that that
can't possibly happen.
There's no free lunch.
There's no arbitrage, on
average, over circumstances.
However, if the
bullet is minus 0.5,
then you've got
lots of opportunity
to create really attractive
portfolios that doesn't require
Warren Buffett's skills.
There's no forecasting here.
Right?
We're not trying to pick stocks.
We're not trying to see
how the market's going
to do next month.
Who knows?
All we're assuming is
that means and variances
are stable over time,
and the correlation
is stable over time.
Those are nontrivial
assumptions, I grant you.
But if you believe
in those assumptions
more than you believe
in your ability
to forecast what's going
to happen to General Motors
six months from now, then
this might be a good way
to construct a portfolio.
But I haven't told you where
on this curve you ought to be.
I just told you how to
construct that curve.
All right?
It's your job to look
at the curve and say,
I like this point,
or I like that point,
based upon your own
personal preferences
for risk and reward.
So we're not there yet where
I can tell you how to behave.
I will get there in about
a lecture and a half.
But we've got to build
up the infrastructure
to be able to get us there.
OK.
So what this tells
us is that we need
to know what the correlation
is in order to figure out
where we are going to be on
these different curves, which
curve is going to apply.
When you have lots
of correlation,
a correlation of 1, there
really isn't much of a risk
savings per unit return.
We can't get a lower risk
for a given level of return.
But we can if there is less
correlation than perfect.
And these are the different
curves that illustrate that.
OK.
So there are some other
examples that I'd like you
to work through on your own.
This is another
portfolio calculation.
Just go through the same
calculations that we did here.
And you know, you'll graph the
different risk/reward trade off
between these two, General
Dynamics and Motorola.
And you can get exactly
the same analysis
with those two stocks,
General Dynamics and Motorola.
OK?
Now what about if you
got a risk free rate?
So suppose that the two
assets that I want to look at
is not General Motors and
Motorola, but rather the stock
market and treasury bills.
Then what does your risk/reward
trade off look like?
Well, it turns out that in the
case where treasury bills are
in question, the volatility
of treasury bills
is virtually zero.
It's not exactly
zero because there
may be some kind of randomness
in the underlying rates
of return because of
inflationary expectations.
But as an approximation,
if it's a risk free rate
and you know that you're going
to get that risk free rate,
then the volatility
of that return
is in fact 0 over
that period of time.
So in that case, the expected
rate of return of a portfolio
between the stock
market and T-bills,
that's the weighted average.
But the variance is going to
be very simple because it's
going to be the variance
of 1, which is 0,
plus the variance
of the other, plus 2
times the weighted average
times the covariance.
But there is no covariance.
Right?
There's no correlation
because one of the things
is non-random.
And so when you work out
the weights for the two
and you graph
them, you get this.
This is a beautiful thing, nice
and simple, no weird curves
or any kind of bullet shape.
You've got T-bills here.
You've got the
stock market here.
And the weights,
as you vary them,
will bring you anywhere
along this line or possibly
up over here.
If you're in the middle of
this line-- so literally,
if you have the same distance
between here and here and here
and here--
that actually gives
you a 50-50 weighting
on those portfolio weights.
So geometrically, this
actually corresponds
to a 50-50 weighting of
T-bills and the S&P. OK?
Now question, what happens
when you are over here?
Let's suppose you're
at this point.
At this point, what would your
portfolio weights look like?
How would you characterize that?
Yeah, Brian?
AUDIENCE: Short T-bills to
buy into the stock market?
ANDREW LO: That's right.
Short T-bills.
What does it mean
to short T-bills?
What are you doing?
You're borrowing.
You're borrowing money.
You're leveraging.
When you're shorting
T-bills, you're
basically borrowing and
getting cash upfront
you're to pay back
later with interest.
So shorting T-bills
is just borrowing.
If you're borrowing money
and you're putting it
into the stock market in
addition to 100% of your own
wealth-- you've borrowed
additional money to put it
in the stock market--
then you're going
to be way up here.
Higher return, much higher
up here than down here,
but you're going to get
higher risk, as well.
So leverage, this idea
of borrowing and putting
your money in the stock
market, that increases
your expected rate of return.
But it also increases your risk.
OK?
Leverage increases your risk.
And now getting back to the
question that Lewis asked us,
is this where we
got into trouble
with the current crisis?
Yes, in a nutshell it is.
But it's more complicated
because the underlying
securities are more complex.
But the basic idea is
if you leverage up,
if you leverage
up, way up here--
you're up maybe out there--
and all of a sudden
there's a bump in the road
and what you are leveraging,
this thing that you're
investing in is not nearly
as smooth and as riskless
as you thought it was,
it could wipe you out.
And one of those elements that
could cause such a wipeout
is if you somehow
forgot about the fact
that correlations can change.
So you thought that you were,
I don't know, somewhere here,
and all of a sudden
correlations go to 1
and now you're
actually over here.
You see how risk can
change really quickly?
Correlations don't have
to be stable over time.
And that's the lesson that
most people in industry,
who don't have a finance
background, who've never taken
this course, they won't know.
These are physicists
or mathematicians
or computer scientists.
They estimate the correlation.
It's a parameter, like
the gravitational constant
or Avogadro's number.
Let's plug it in.
Hey, 9.08 times 10 the 23rd,
that's what it should be.
And nobody ever told them
that it could change.
And when it changes, bad things
can happen really quickly.
So we're going to
come back to that.
But let's get the standard
theory down first,
and then we'll talk a
bit about application.
Anon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
ANDREW LO: Right here?
Of course.
Because you might want to
get more return and you're
willing to take on risk.
Let's take a look at this.
This bullet point
here says that you're
going to be at
approximately, something--
if the correlation-- let's
be realistic about it.
OK?
The correlation is not
going to be minus 0.5.
It's going to be more like 0.37.
So this bullet here is
going to be like 1--
I don't know, let's call it
1.3% just to make it easy.
And you've got a standard
deviation of about 6%.
OK?
So on an annualized
basis, that's
giving you a return, 1.3 times
12 is something like what, 16%?
16% return, but the risk on
an annualized basis multiplied
by 3 and 1/2 is
about, let's say 20%.
So 20%, 22% annual
standard deviation
for a 16% rate of return.
Now some of you might like that.
But I have a few
friends here for whom
that return is just boring.
That's just not going
to get their attention.
What they want is they
want to be up here,
you know, like at
2% rate of return.
2% rate of return per
month is about 24% a year.
So if you're a
hedge fund manager,
24% is when you start
to begin to feel alive.
You know?
That's when things really
start to happen for you.
And at 24% annual
return, you can't
have volatility
of like 15% or 20%
unless you're doing
something, you
know, really different than
the standard market portfolio.
So a hedge fund manager is going
to say, Anon, give me a break.
You know, this is going
to put me to sleep.
I want to be up here.
But you know, you've got
a family, three kids,
you have to worry about
making mortgage payments.
That kind of lifestyle
is not for you.
So in both cases,
though, in both cases,
we can agree that where we want
to be is on this curve, right?
In other words, you would never
want to be here, at this point.
Why?
Because if you were
here, you can either,
for the same level of
risk, increase your return.
Or for the same level of
return, decrease your risk.
So what we can agree
on, even though we
don't agree on where we
want to be on that curve,
we can all agree we want to
be on that curve as opposed
to inside the curve.
Right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Exactly.
Great point.
Why would we want to
be on the bottom half?
Nobody would want to do that.
Because if were on
the bottom half,
you can just as easily
move up to the top,
and you have a higher
expected rate of return
for the same level of risk.
So you're exactly right.
That bottom half of the curve,
you can just throw it away.
All right?
The only people that are
going to be down there
are knuckleheads.
All right?
So we don't want
to be down there.
So in fact, the only part of
the curve that really matters
is this point, going
all the way up.
And we're going to give a
name to that in a minute.
That's going to be called the
efficient frontier because you
would never want to
do anything else.
Actually, that's not quite true.
What everybody would like to do
is they'd like to be up here.
Unfortunately, we
can't get there.
We can't get there with just
General Motors and Motorola.
In a few minutes,
I'm going to show you
how you might be able to
get there with other stocks.
If you introduce
other assets, then you
might be able to get there.
But you can't get
there right now.
OK.
So here we are with
stocks and T-bills.
And we know that we'll get
the linear combination here.
What I'd like to do next is to
make this yet more complicated.
All right?
And before I do, let
me just summarize
what we've done so far.
What we've done is to
show that with two assets,
we can do all of
this analytically,
and illustrate graphically,
all of the intuition that holds
for the more general case.
With two assets, the
expected rate of return
is just a simple
weighted average.
But the variance is not just
a simple weighted average.
It's more complicated and
it depends, in particular,
on the correlation.
For different correlations,
we get different shapes
of trade offs in
mean-variance space.
And you have to understand
what those trade offs are.
If it turns out that one of
the two assets is T-bills,
for example, then the trade
off is really straight line.
OK?
But if both assets
are risky, then you
get the bullet shape until
you either get minus 1 or 1
in terms of correlations.
And then you get straight
lines of different stripes
in those two different cases.
OK.
Now we're ready to talk
about the general case.
The general case works exactly
the same as the two asset case.
You've got your means.
You've got your variances.
And you've got your covariances.
And you add up all of
these different covariances
to get the total variance
of the portfolio.
And if you consider a
couple of simple cases,
like for example, an
equal weighted portfolio--
so you've got n assets
and you put each of your--
for each of your assets, you
put 1 over n of your wealth
in them.
Then you can show
that the variance
of your entire portfolio is
equal to the average variance
plus n times n minus 1 times
the average covariance.
When n gets large,
then it turns out
that the average
variance doesn't matter.
What is driving the
risk of your portfolio
has nothing to do
with the variance
of the individual components.
What it has to do with is what
the average covariance is.
That's what's driving the
risk of your portfolio.
Because you've got a
lot more covariances
than you do variances.
OK?
So this is kind
of a neat insight
because it says that
it's really important how
things are related.
And as those
relationships change,
the risk of your portfolio
is going to change.
So getting back to
Lewis's point about what's
going on in current
markets and what
caught a lot of
portfolio managers
by surprise with the
subprime markets,
if the risk of your portfolio
is approximately given
by the average covariance
and you've been assuming
all along that you've got
this big pool of mortgages,
and the mortgages
are all uncorrelated,
you've essentially assumed that
you've got virtually no risk.
Because the average
covariance by assumption
and by historical
analysis is close to zero.
But when the real state
market goes down nationally,
then everybody
starts to default.
And foreclosures become
very highly correlated.
And so you can see how
overnight, literally overnight,
your risks can shoot up.
And you're not prepared
for that unless you
know that this is what's
going on in your portfolio.
Yup?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Great question.
Why should things change
in terms of correlation?
Well, you know what?
I'll give you an example.
I'll give you a
personal example?
Correlation is a function
of human behavior, right?
I mean, prices are being
formed by you and I, investors.
And so correlations simply
means that all of us
end up doing the same
thing around to same time.
Right?
I'm going to be heading to the
airport later on this evening.
And I don't expect
that there's going
to be much of a big deal
getting on my flight.
I'll probably get to the
airport about half an hour,
45 minutes ahead of time.
It's just a shuttle.
So I'm heading to Washington,
so it's not a big deal.
What's going to happen
in two weeks from today?
Anything?
Anything going on two weeks from
today that you can think of?
Thanksgiving.
So if I went to the airport
two weeks from today
and tried to get on that
shuttle half an hour before,
you think I can
get on the flight?
Why not?
Because everybody else
is going to do that.
Well, why should everything
be correlated on that day?
Isn't that a Wednesday
like every other Wednesday?
Well, it's not.
It's because somehow
we've all decided
that we're going to take
off at the same time
on the same day in that year.
Right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Well, first of all,
I don't think Thanksgiving
is that low a probability.
OK?
But to your point, is that
the correlation changing?
Well, it is.
Correlation is a statistical
measure of two objects.
And what we're trying to capture
is when they move up or down
at the same time.
Right?
So what I'm trying to
get at is that there
are certain periods
of time where
human behavior, all of a sudden,
becomes very highly correlated.
And there are many
reasons for that.
In particular,
Thanksgiving is a reason
we all decide that Thursday
is this national holiday.
And therefore, on that
Wednesday, we actually
have to travel in
order to get to where
we need to go by Thursday.
Right?
But any arbitrary
Wednesday is not
going to be necessarily
highly correlated.
So when I go to the airport
on a typical Wednesday,
I don't expect it to be so bad.
But on Wednesday
before Thanksgiving,
it's going to be a madhouse.
Right?
That's an example of
a changing correlation
because of a
particular coordination
that we've all agreed upon.
Now that's a relatively
artificial example.
But I did it to make a point.
Now let me give
you a real answer
to your question about why
things may be correlated.
When we are all scared about
the value of our investments,
when our fear circuitry
gets triggered,
what's the natural instinct
for all of us because it's
hardwired into our brains?
It's to get to safety.
It's to get out of
those bad assets
and get into the good assets.
Right?
You saw that three month T-bill
yield at 10 basis points, or 5
basis points?
That's a sign that we're
all scared to death
and we want to get to safety.
That's an example
of a correlation.
Why?
Because everybody is going to
be selling at the same time.
In a crowded theater, if you
smell smoke and somebody shouts
fire, what are you going to do?
It's not rocket
science to predict
that the four exits
that are out there
will be a bit
crowded after that.
Right?
So correlation is not
a physical quantity.
That's the problem with
physics and biology.
Physics has parameters that
don't change over time.
I wish we could have
that in finance.
We don't.
We have parameters that
are not parameters.
They're random variables.
They depend on a lot of things.
Correlation is one of them.
And until we start recognizing
that correlations are really
part and partial of
human interactions,
we're going to continue to
make mistakes like we've
made over the last 10 years.
And that's a simple
example of that.
Other question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Yes.
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
That's true.
That's possible.
So you have to decide whether
or not what you're looking at
is an aberration,
or whether it's
something that's systematic.
So for example, if I didn't
know anything about Thanksgiving
and I happened to travel on
Wednesdays on a regular basis
to Washington, then
you know, in two weeks,
I'll get-- it's really crowded.
And then it won't be
crowded, won't be crowded,
won't be crowded.
And pretty soon,
after a while, I'll
say, well, that was
just a 1% event.
Of course, next year
it will happen again.
And then I'll say, gee, you
know, well, that's another 1%,
kind of.
But pretty soon I'm going to
realize that, gee, it seems
like there's a pattern here.
And that 1%, it's not just
so simple as a 1% error.
Statistics, remember, is a
mathematical quantification
of our stupidity.
Right?
I mean, what we don't know.
Well, we don't know why things
happen the way they happen,
so we put a distribution on it.
We say that it's normal.
And we say that there's
5% this way, 5% that way.
But that just is
a representation
of our ignorance.
The more we know, the less we
have to rely on statistics.
So I don't need
statistics to tell me
that two weeks from
now, it's going
to be really crowded at Logan.
But if I didn't know
about Thanksgiving,
if I came from Mars and I
was doing a study of airport
congestion, it would
take me a while
to get enough data
to figure out that
once a year on the Wednesday
before the Thursday
in, you know, November,
it gets crowded.
So the challenge for all of
you is how much intelligence
can you bring to the analysis.
What I'm showing you is
very simple mathematics.
Mathematics is not enough.
If you just had the
mathematics, you
would be losing money,
you know, continuously.
Because there's just much more
to financial markets than just
the math.
OK?
The math is trivial.
This is high school algebra.
But the real key
is to put together
the framework of economic
and financial analysis
with the mathematics.
So let me continue doing that.
This is another example of
computing the average variance,
and then looking
at the volatility
of your particular holdings,
given different correlations.
So I want you to do
lots of exercises
where you look at
different correlations.
I don't ever want you
to take correlation
as a parameter that
is fixed over time,
when you apply the stuff.
When you're doing problem sets
in final exams, that's fine.
You know, the correlation
is whatever it is.
But recognize that in
practice, these things
change a lot over time.
OK?
Now the idea behind
correlation is
that they help
you reduce the ups
and the downs of the
variance of your portfolio.
But it turns out that there's
a limit to how much of the risk
you can reduce.
And this graph basically
shows that as you
add more and more securities--
even though the correlations
are bouncing around--
as you add more and
more securities,
there ends up being some
kind of a steady state
limit to what the variance
of your overall portfolio is.
After 20, 30, 40,
50, 100 stocks,
you'll notice that the
variance of your portfolio
doesn't go down anymore.
And it turns out that that
limit, whatever that is,
is what we consider to be
the systematic risk that
is implicit in the economy.
In other words, that's the
risk that no matter how well
diversified you are, you've
got to bear that risk.
Everybody, all of
us, we have to,
we can't get any
less risky than that
unless we start putting
our money in the mattress
or in T-bills.
OK?
That limit is known as the
systematic, or market risk,
of a portfolio.
So, see here is the graph
of your portfolio variance
as you increase more
and more securities.
But at some point, it
asymptotes to this level,
which is what I'm going
to be focusing on,
as undiversifiable risk.
It's the risk that's
left over after all
of the various correlations
have done what they
can to dampen the ups and
the downs of your collection
of securities.
And obviously,
there's going to be
some calculations you'll
need to do to figure out
what that number is.
But I want to give you
the intuition first,
and then we'll do
the calculations.
And then we're going
to study the properties
of this hard limit.
OK?
Now, I'm about to proceed to
the next stage of our analysis
where we start
asking the question,
how do we pick the very
best possible portfolio.
But before I do, I
want to make sure
that everybody is comfortable
with the analytics
we've developed.
If you have any questions, now
would be a good time to ask.
Because from this
point on, I'm going
to assume that you understand
how portfolio theory works,
the mechanics of
portfolio weights,
and how to compute means,
variances, covariances,
and what they imply
for the portfolio.
Question, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Earlier,
you said that we
start from this, ensuring that
the markets are pretty much
stable.
But I'm wondering, how
reasonable is that assumption?
And why would nobody ever pick
a lower part of on the curve,
for example, you know, if there
was a big scandal tomorrow,
like a corruption, like
I'm thinking about Enron
or [INAUDIBLE] in Italy.
Why would I not want to
short sell, you know,
the higher return stock and
buy the lower return stock,
and take the lower
part of the curve?
ANDREW LO: You might, if
there are other elements that
are in this analysis.
So as I said, this
analysis assumes
there are only two dimensions,
mean and standard deviation.
Right?
You've now introduced
a third, which
is corporate responsibility
or corporate governance
or fraud or something like that.
Then you would need
three dimensions.
And there'd be something
sticking outside the screen.
And then you'd have to choose
among the three possibilities.
So it's possible
that you want to be
down here because this company
has a better reputation
than this one up here.
But then what
you're telling me is
that reputation matters to
you beyond standard deviation
and expected return.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Market conditions.
ANDREW LO: Stable means
that these parameters
are likely to stay
the same over time.
AUDIENCE: There's a
crisis every three years.
There's an industry
crisis every two years.
ANDREW LO: Right.
Well, the argument that
a financial economist
would make--
and I'm not saying
that I believe in this.
I'm going to tell
you what I believe
at the end of this class.
But I'm telling you now
what the party line is,
and what's in your textbook.
What's in your textbook
and what the party line is
is that when you use
historical amounts of data,
those kind of crisis periods
are in there already.
So if I estimate
the correlations,
including October '87, including
March 2000, the bursting
of the internet bubble,
August 1998, LTCM,
if I include all of
those in my data,
then it's captured in there.
Right?
It's not captured today.
In other words, this point
here for General Dynamics
doesn't reflect that
there's a crisis today.
What it reflects is, on average,
over a long period of time--
some of which includes crises--
that's what the expected
return looks like.
And so I've already incorporated
that into the parameters.
And if it so happens that
today is a bad day for General
Dynamics, that
shouldn't influence
whether you buy it or not.
Because what you should
be thinking about
is over the next 15 or 20
years, how will my portfolio do.
So that's another difference
in perspective from us
versus Warren Buffett.
Although actually, not
as much as you think.
Warren Buffett typically takes
a long term perspective, right?
His investment in Goldman Sachs?
We all thought it
was a great deal.
He's lost money in it
since he put that money
in a few weeks ago.
But is he worried about it?
I don't think so.
Because he's invested in it
for the next 15 to 20 years.
And I believe, as he does,
that he got a great deal
over that time period.
So if you care about what's
going to happen tomorrow,
then all of the things
that I'm telling you,
you should not take
that as seriously.
Because these kind of
parameters aren't made for day
to day forecasting.
Then you need to get
hedge fund models.
And for that, you need
to take not only 433,
but a number of other
courses, and courses
that aren't even offered yet.
Because frankly, if I
told you how to do it,
I'd have to kill you.
Right?
Highly proprietary.
But this is the
approach where we're not
trying to forecast markets.
And so I'm acknowledging
that you're
right that there
are instabilities.
But as long as I'm using a
long enough amount of data,
that it's in there.
It's captured in there,
in that set of parameters.
OK?
If it's not, if you know of
something that's not in here,
obviously you can't expect this
to give you the right answer.
And you have to adjust your
use of this technology,
accordingly.
Other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
That's right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Well,
you have to know
how to build those
other variables
into this kind of a framework.
That's another
way of putting it.
So in other words,
this framework
is still useful
in the case where
you've got other variables.
But you just need to know how
those other variables will
impact the parameters
for this analysis.
If you can figure that out, then
you're a hedge fund manager.
Right?
That's what hedge
funds try to do.
They try to figure out
how all of these relations
impact on how to construct
a good portfolio.
All right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: That's right.
For example.
That would be one
way of looking at it.
But there are other ways.
It doesn't have to
be quantitative.
There are a lot of talented
hedge fund managers
that don't know how
to use a calculator,
make a lot of money.
OK?
So don't think that it's all
about quantitative analysis.
That's what we think.
That's how I think.
That's how MIT may think.
But that's not the only way
to make money out there.
You know, Warren
Buffett, I don't think
knows how to calculate
these covariances.
But he's done OK.
So but I think what we can
do with this framework is
to analyze how he
does what he does,
and understand it in the context
of this kind of a framework.
All right.
So let's now go to the next
topic, which is, all right,
how do we choose
a good portfolio,
given what we now know
about this framework?
Well, we said before--
Ryan pointed out--
that we never want
to be on the lower
part of that frontier.
So that's one thing we know.
Right?
We don't want to be
on the bottom part.
So we want to be on
the efficient frontier.
Now this entire
bullet can be viewed
as what's called the
minimum variance boundary.
Meaning, for any given
investment over here,
we have the absolute
minimum variance
that has the same level
of expected return.
So when I go, when
I go horizontally,
I'm looking at the
smallest amount
of risk I can take for
that same level of expected
rate of return.
That's what this bullet can
be viewed as giving you.
And it turns out that because
we like expected return,
and we don't like
risk, we want to be
on the upper part
of that bullet.
So this upper part is known
as the efficient frontier.
So that's the one thing we can
tell about portfolio theory.
It's that we want to
be on the upper branch.
But where on the
upper branch depends
upon our risk preferences.
OK?
So here's a concrete example.
Suppose you can invest in
any combination of General
Motors, IBM, and Motorola.
What portfolio would you choose?
So these are the data
that you would start with.
OK?
The means and the standard
deviations, and then of course,
the covariances.
You've got to have
the covariances to be
able to calculate that bullet.
So you can invest
in any combination.
What would you choose?
Let's calculate the
expected rate of return
and the variance
of that portfolio.
And you want to ask
the question, what
looks good to you?
OK?
Well, it turns out
that when you calculate
this kind of a bullet,
you find out something
that's, yet again, amazing.
What you find is that
the bullet actually
is better than any of the three
stocks that you started with.
So look at where the
three stocks are--
General Motors,
IBM, and Motorola--
and the bullet, look
at where the bullet is.
The bullet is strictly to the
northwest of these stocks.
Right?
In other words, you can do
better than any one of these,
either by going here
or by going here.
For the same level of risk,
you can get a higher return.
For the same level of expected
return, you can get lower risk.
OK?
So the first point is
that portfolio theory,
for multiple stocks, is
even more compelling.
Because now, with
those two stocks,
at least the two stocks were on
that minimum variance boundary.
Now, with three
stocks and more, it's
possible that none
of the stocks are
going to be on the
minimum variance boundary.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What I don't
understand is this.
S This is backward looking.
So if people between companies
and so on all make this graph
and they all decide to
strategize based on this graph,
the price of these
stocks next day
are going to be correlated
in a different way
than you expect because
it's going to effect the--
ANDREW LO: Very good point.
But it turns out your
conclusion is false.
But that's a good
question to ask.
And I'm going to answer that,
not today, but on Monday.
When we go over
the question, what
happens when
everybody does it, I'm
going to deal with
that question head on.
OK?
That's going to be a
very important point.
And this is going to be one of
the very few instances where
when everybody does what I
tell you they're going to do,
that's actually going to
give you an equilibrium.
And everything will work
out in just the right way.
That's the magic of the CAPM.
But you're right that
Warren Buffett could not
answer that criticism.
If you talk to Warren
Buffett and said,
Warren, if everybody did what
you did, then it wouldn't work.
And he would say, you know what?
That's right.
That's why nobody can
ever do what I do.
I'm just smarter
than everybody else.
And so, I'm sorry.
That's the way it goes.
Here, I'm not appealing
to everybody being
smarter than everybody else.
Because frankly, we're not.
What I'm appealing to,
what I will appeal to,
is if everybody does the right
thing-- by the right thing,
I'm about to tell you what
that right thing is-- everybody
is on that upper
branch and maximizes
their risk/reward trade off,
a very special thing happens.
All right?
I'm going to keep that
as a surprise for Monday.
OK, question?
A question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW LO: Yeah.
Well, first of
all, it's not clear
that Warren Buffett
is number one.
All right?
He's got a long track record
and he's got the biggest pie.
But in terms of
actual track record,
he doesn't have the
best track record.
There are people
that you've never
heard of that have
a better track
record than Warren Buffett.
For example, there's a fellow
by the name of James Simons--
who I may have mentioned earlier
on as a hedge fund manager--
who also happens to be a
first rate mathematician,
who started up a
hedge fund called
Renaissance Technologies.
That is probably the
single best track
record of any manager in
the history of investments.
And he does it completely
quantitatively,
completely automated.
He hires something like 100
PhDs that work on nothing else
but how to forecast the
next minute, as well as
the next hour, the next year.
It's an extraordinary
track record.
So there are a number
of folks like that.
Let me not dwell
on that, but I'll
come back to that
in a few lectures
when we talk about
performance attribution.
OK.
So I'm going to leave you
with one final thought
since we're out of time.
There is going to be a
very special role played
by a portfolio called
the Tangency Portfolio.
And I want you to think about
how your risk/reward trade off
would look when
you mix your T-bill
risk-free asset with arbitrary
portfolios on this bullet.
Think about what that
trade off would look like.
And ask yourself
the question, does
there exist a special portfolio
on that efficient frontier
that everybody in this classroom
is going to want to have?
All right?
I want you to identify them.
And I'm going to ask you
that question on Monday,
and I expect an answer.
All right?
I'll see you on Monday.